before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
look I'll just be honest he did look
pretty good on that horse
thank you
flux continues and we've arrived at what
was to my memory the good episode of
flux
the way that I remembered this was that
yes there's some of the overarching
stuff that at first viewing may or may
not end up paying off later but that the
my the main body of this dealing with
the sontarns and all that is not only
decent it's some of the better stuff
chibinal has done
I don't know how much I stand by that
I mean
grading on the scale of chimnal's work
as showrunner it might still be some of
the better stuff he's done but
it's worse than I remember
well sort of the stuff that I remembered
is basically what I remembered it being
it doesn't land quite as well
um you know the stuff set in the war
um you know the various characters some
of the moments with the suntarens
they're all decent but I think in a way
it really benefited from lower
expectations the Halloween apocalypse
really put me in a position of going oh
God is this going to be all bad and this
felt like something like oh okay this is
actually pretty decent I feel like I'm
my memory gave a more benefit of the
doubt because while it's decent that
stuff is at least it's also not
particularly exceptional once the
novelty wears off the novelty of things
like the suntarens looking more like
they did back in classic era doctor
which I do like the original appearance
of the sontarens
in Time Warrior Commander links who gets
name dropped here which I also loved
that's one of my favorite classic era
stories it might well be my favorite
Third Doctor story
and so I'm a sucker for that you know we
have you know fun moments and lines from
the santarns where they are still
allowed to be funny but they're not made
completely stupid so you can have lines
like
you will be stamps
that's fun that's funny that's that's a
mockery of the warrior mentality and
again that goes back to the roots of the
santarans the first thing Lynx did in
the time Warrior getting out of his
little egg-shaped spaceship was plant a
flag on a planet he knew nothing about
because that's just how they are that
was all good and fun and funny
I found Mary Seacole to be kind of
interesting largely because speaking as
an American she's not someone who I knew
a ton about so I was more forgiving of
the Wikipedia style Exposition used to
explain her because
this was new information for me so I was
more forgiving of that
so the thing is that that kind of stuff
that novelty that pop of oh oh old
Santana design oh Link's reference oh I
don't know her
that's the stuff that doesn't last on a
re-watch
and once that wears off what's left with
the santaren stuff is
it's decent it works
but it's not
it's not much to write home about
the bigger problem ultimately is that
the non-sontaren stuff takes up a
significantly bigger percentage of this
than I remembered
I think that was my brain forcibly kind
of shoving
all of the non-sontaren stuff to the
side
in you know under a vague category of
I'll know what this means later
and to my memory it was a lot less of
the episode than it ended up proving to
be upon re-watch
and given how I feel about the
overarching story
yeah having more of it than I thought
was in here
not great
not great at all especially as we're
starting to dip into some of the just
real nonsense and I don't just mean
narrative nonsense I mean why would you
even do that so like we get introduced
here to the concept of the Mori
and these beings that are somehow
responsible for
containing time
now there's some things here there's a
phrase even that I'm like
I want to know what that looks like
because that sounds fascinating there's
the phrase time would run wild
oh
but the show this episode at least until
my memory of the Season as a whole we'll
see doesn't really dive into that idea
it felt like it could have almost been a
second bite at the Apple to the thing
that Moffitt completely dropped the ball
on
um back in series
six the um
what was it the the wedding of River
Song where like all of time was
happening at once was just a thing they
say at the beginning and the show does
almost nothing with that concept this
again like and here they do even less
they just say time would run wild and
like this weird upside down pyramid
repair Droid or whatever the heck it is
has this line like
[Music]
I'm like what
what and this
I I'm not trying to jump ahead but
knowing where this is going or at least
my understanding of where it's going and
that like we're going to actually meet
eventually an embodiment of time
I
I don't know why I don't know why any of
this I don't know why trying to drop
this sort of intrigue of time is evil
what is it what
like it would have been more interesting
if it was left as the abstract but I
know that's not going to be the case
they're actually going to personify it
which is so weird to me but also like
just the general Trope of oh if not for
these few beings everything would come
apart which is just it's a really lazy
Trope it's a really lazy way to raise
the stakes to say that like
reality itself or everything would fall
apart or follow to ruin or tear itself
apart if not for this one McGuffin
these few people like
no that's not you've scaled it too big
you're saying all of time and space
falls apart if
these people aren't standing in these
exact same places doing
I don't know what you don't really
explain what it is they do
and they're I mean technically they're
people and because it allows them to
like put Yaz and space of of one of
these things but like
narratively they they might as well be a
fuse box
why would you make them people that that
just raises a bajillion questions
that again to my memory this thing
doesn't answer but I'll try I'll try and
pay attention on the next one because I
remember the next one being an absolute
disaster but I'll try and pay as much
attention as I can to that but even
coming back to the centaurens it's it's
light it has a good sense of fun I do
enjoy it but it's
like I said a lot of the best parts of
it
just kind of have that initial pop of
recognition or Nostalgia or novelty
you don't get that on a re-watch you
just don't and we are starting to pile
up the things that don't ever get
properly explained so
I completely forgotten that this is
there but when Yaz and Dan start to fade
out and go to different times and places
there is an offhand explanation from the
doctor it has to do with the way in
which the vortex energy that she had
tried to fire at the flux is intermixing
with the flux energy and that's causing
them to kind of for Life a better way to
put it become unstuck in time
that's
fine that's a perfectly serviceable
technobabble explanation for why Yaz and
Dan
fade away but also why the three of them
survived getting hit by the flux the
time Vortex energy didn't stop it but it
did create enough of a wibbly wobbly
effect that instead of being destroyed
they were they and the Tardis were
thrown through time and space cool
that works that functions how did vendor
end up in that freaking Temple of
whatever with the Mori how did he end up
there
because he got hit by the flux to my
memory
but he there was no time Vortex for him
or heck
why are swarm and Azure here and what is
passenger that just shows up now again I
remember passenger is going to be kind
of explained later but again the way
it's introduced and it's just dropped
and it's one more thing of okay but what
the hell is that now and swarmin Azure
I'm
I'm really gonna be curious
because at this moment in time at time
of recording
I can't remember
if swarmin Azure are actually
responsible for the flux or not
because if they're not
why is all of this going on at once
what are they doing in this story if
they're not responsible for that
eating up time and again as I said last
I'm giving decent enough performances
All Things Considered but they show up
and they're just they're talking through
the the standard villainous sort of
monologue kind of stuff you know showing
off that uh you can't hit me with your
gun and whatnot and like it's all
functional it's fine but I still don't
know who these people are I don't know
what they want
swarm obviously wants to hurt the doctor
okay why and like I guess we've just
decided they just know things
shame disgrace and rejected like they
know who Yaz is and I guess by extension
that is supposed to be meant to answer
my question that they just know who die
is uh the the woman that Dan was going
to go on the day with that they
kidnapped last time although I still
don't understand even if they knew who
she was and knew that somehow Dan would
end up connected to the doctor
what do they need her for I I can't
remember if that gets answered like why
they targeted her or not but again just
just granting villains omniscience
where suddenly they just know a bunch of
stuff they shouldn't know well how do
they know oh that's how you know they're
powerful no that's how you know the
writing is just lazy
and I don't need an explanation for
everything heck there are times that I
Revel in a lack of explanations on
certain things but there are other times
where like no this begs a lot of
questions that you're just moving
forward as if they don't exist
and that doesn't feel like a deliberate
choice to keep certain things mysterious
that feels like a mistake that feels
like you didn't realize the questions
that your own story was bringing up you
don't seem to be aware that you're
raising questions at all it's
frustrating
because as I said to my memory this is
the good one
and it does have decent moments I like
the playing off of the pompousness of
the uh of the British officer which yeah
that tracks I don't have a problem
taking a head or two of that but like
why are they remembered as having always
been there how did they supersede Russia
why would they do that and if they have
done that and they've got the weapons
that they do why haven't they already
won
again these are the kind of things that
if this was properly the entirety of the
episode and it didn't have to share
space with the flux stuff there was time
to answer these questions but not when
it's got to share space with all this
other stuff so what we end up with is a
cut down Cliffs notes almost kind of
virgin virgin version of a santaren
story that could have been better if it
had just been afforded the entire
episode run time to itself
but instead it has to share it with this
other stuff and
it's lesser for it even though it is
very much the better material and the
stronger stuff oh and I'm sure some
people are going to mention in the
comments
Comics comments why can't I talk the
comments the whole thing with Dan and
like he's running away from the
suntarens they can't seem to hit him
from like a few yards away like it's not
good I'm not gonna defend it I will say
it doesn't bother me I'm nearly as much
as say the stuff last episode when the
drones couldn't hit the doctrine Yaz who
were just hanging there because they
literally were just hanging there Dan
was at least running like they should be
able to hit him he's not running that
fast he's not serpentining or anything
like they should be able to hit him I'm
not going to disagree with that but that
strikes me much more as like a a bad
directing choice that you shouldn't have
made that the angle you should have cut
it in a way to obfuscate how close they
were to him because yeah it's really not
bad in concept but it's ruined by that
angle also like I'm wondering at this
point what's the point of azure is it
just so swarm
I don't know has a visual compliment
like again her design I think is pretty
nifty and her performances decent
I don't get why she's there
like her appearance raised a ton of
questions for me in the last episode and
then on top of that I just don't
I just don't know what she brings
that isn't just provided by the one guy
who's eating up most of the run time
it it feels less like they that swarm
and Azure are two characters with a
dynamic and it feels more like the same
character was written twice if you want
an example of what it is I'm trying to
compare this to you can look at the
episode can you hear me and the
characters of zelen and rakaya who are
very similar in a lot of ways but also
are distinct enough that they have a
clear Dynamic and it's not just the same
character twice if they both effectively
do the same thing and have the same
function there's really no need for
there to be two of them it's redundant
again like I'm largely disappointed in
this but
again again
yeah
there's still enjoyment to be had here
and this is probably the one I'm going
to enjoy uh the most still
unless like something really turns
around for me in the later ones which I
have a hard time believing but hey
stranger things have happened or so I've
heard but yeah War for the suntarens or
no war of the center you know what I'm
just gonna go to bed I'm gonna I'm gonna
finish recording this and I'm gonna go
to bed because my brain has decided that
it's done and I'm gonna take that as my
cue to ask you what did you think about
this episode have you rewatched it
lately whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon pays the bills and
enables me to do this as my living even
if you cannot assist me with that
um anything that you feel like doing
checking out other things that I do in
the description liking sharing
subscribing all that stuff's great don't
worry too much about it though because
what I really want you to remember
you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you're at the council I'm just running
the meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
sorry
massive thanks to my patreon supporters
and in particular I want to thank Robin
Moore Zubin look full up to rock the
thing that goes doink in the anime Ruth
Oliver B solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen the
oatha Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
bernabe likes the poodle Robin Powell
Tracy scrabot angry casparo Adam RDL
Taylor David Hall Shayla gourlay and
Rosalind Bennett thanks for your support
you can get your name in the credits too
if you feel like hearing me possibly
with it for several times before getting
it right
[Music]
foreign